uh the minister for business and
industry nadine zahari is with me now
good morning thank you for joining us
this morning minister
why would putting greater manchester and
lancashire under tier three restrictions
be the right decision well this is
really difficult
it's it's a balance between effectively
two harms the harm of the
virus is doing and then obviously the
harm
um to the economy and also to health
actually
of having a national uh
lockdown so the local lockdowns is the
best way forward
the uh decisions are made um with a
heavy heart really hard decisions
uh whether it be in liverpool with steve
rotherham there
and i have to pay tribute to him the
work we did with him over the weekend
was
pretty remarkable and i hope we can do
this differently i hope we can do the
same very happy
well no one is happy look nobody's happy
as i said we do this with a heavy heart
and i hope we can do the same with andy
burnham uh and other parts of the
country clearly as well not just
obviously greater manchester uh but
london and elsewhere
as well none of these decisions are made
easily but it's a balance because we
have to bring the infection numbers down
because
as they begin to spike and you've heard
chris sweetie talk about this
uh that we have to get the um the
numbers down
the tiers are the best way to do this
they're much simpler much easier people
to understand
where they are in their area the app now
has been downloaded by 17 million people
you heard
president macron praise our app they've
had a real problem in france
they've had to sort of delete the app
because they were only downloaded by a
million people we've had 17 million
people here
it now can tell people uh which tier
they're in
and we also people can look on their
postcode
uh to see which tier they're in it's
really difficult okay and i i i say this
to you because
you know you asked me earlier before we
we came went live as to how you know
what do we do it's seven days a week 19
hours a day for
frontline nhs staff obviously um you
know our staff
in each and every department but as i
say we want to work with local leaders
to get this right you know
nobody underestimates the effort that
the government is trying to do of course
nobody wants to see even one single life
lost or one single job and we understand
that potentially
that has to happen or you're doing
everything you can to try to stop that
happening
but back to what we were talking about
um great in manchester and lancashire
under tier three restrictions
um it looks as though they're going that
way uh you said that you worked well
with liverpool the mayor says something
different the mayor of greater
manchester
is going to sue you well i hope we don't
get to that place i you know i know andy
burnham for many many years and we want
to work with andy burnham we've already
put six billion pounds of help um
he he clearly has some some points to
make around the help
so so what if you do go into tier three
there is a
um a support package an economic support
package of
two-thirds of wages being paid for those
obviously businesses which is fabulous
if you're working for boston consultancy
two-thirds of seven thousand pounds a
day is quite a lot of money
to two-thirds of you know which equates
to something like five pounds 50
an hour it's not very much money you
know it's you're not level the playing
field
people feel that they're being left
behind by this government i
don't disagree with you in terms of the
boston consultancy versus someone on
national living wage but if you take
a single person on national living wage
in manchester renting a one-bedroom flat
um between the the two-thirds scheme
and universal credit they'd get about 90
of their
wages paid to them it's not 100 and i
know that and it's difficult to live off
off that i know that too my family had
to go on
when i was young on income support and
housing benefits so i know what it's
like
to have to live um under something like
universal credit although i have to say
you know universal credit has been an
incredible safety net with the
additional 9.3 billion that we put in
not long time ago you know labor during
the general election were asking for it
to be abolished they're not saying that
now i hope
no okay so you're talking about the
number of
jobs the amount of money that is being
paid let me talk to you about the number
of
jobs the reason one of the reasons i'm
sorry i can really hear myself back in
my ear guys i wonder if someone could
sort that out for me
um andy berman say it's a blatant act of
leveling down
and he fears part of the north won't
emerge from tier three measures until
long into the winter he talks about the
number of jobs that are involved 20 000
employed in pubs 20 000 taxi drivers 63
000
in accommodation and food services 7 000
inherent beauty
it goes on 32 000 arts and entertainment
187 000 self-employed that is why he
doesn't want to go into tier three
you're saying tough we're going to do it
anyway no we're not what we're saying is
look
we've got that's what it amounts to what
we're saying is we've got a package
rishi sunak today is now touching 200
billion pounds
of um effectively putting our rounds
around the economy and jobs of course
the
uh if you do go into tier three the two
thousand people
are gonna be effective no i hear you but
you know france is around
sixty percent germany's at seventy
percent don't care don't care my view is
this morning and greater manchester
don't care what's happening
and i hear your viewers they care about
all of those jobs of course and so do we
which is why we
you you get two-thirds of your salary if
you are in a tier three and you you are
closed down
better than you is the greater
manchester but he worked in westminster
he's now up there in greater manchester
he knows better than you guys
that's why you're asking his opinion
he's offering it you're not taking any
notice no we do we do take notice we
talk to andy but
look he's he's clearly um
upset rightly so because this is
difficult this is not easy
what we're saying is look let's keep
working together we're saying two-thirds
of the wages will be paid for those
businesses
that will go into tier three and are
closed down it's imperfect
i know they might not be coming back to
a job after well but but actually
you know two-thirds payment is i think
something that that is right for us to
do it's right to protect
the economy we've already put six
billion pounds to all the local
uh areas that have had been asked to
have local lockdowns
we've now moved to this tiering system
all i would ask andes to do is to just
look keep working with us let's try and
get this right
if we can do this together which is what
our hope is we can suppress this virus
protect the nhs protect lives and come
out the other end
everybody wants of course of course but
you're not including everybody a
conservative
mp in the northwest william rag said he
didn't get an invite
to the meeting today that's being hosted
by helen
waitley um the abzel khan manchester mp
said
last night that he found out on sky news
before he found out
um from the government that there was
going to be a meeting this morning
it's a breakdown in communication that's
why people are angry
that's why they're threatening to see
you what's your response well i would
apologize to afzal
khan and to william rag both colleagues
both important to be
at that meeting it is a fast-moving um
situation you know this k because
you you see it every day i don't
disagree with you i don't your job i
don't disagree with you
so you apologize i apologize and i i
hope that they can be at the meeting and
make time
for that meeting so they can hear
directly from the chief medical officer
from
uh uh the deputy chief medical officer
as to why
we're having to take this action and why
it's important that we work
together well no i'm what i'm saying to
you said why we're taking no what i'm
saying to you is they need to see
the the the data and of course that
decision will be made jointly
with the local leaders that's that's how
we should it wasn't
well no that's not true steve brought
them and and and
are you suggesting that being economical
with the action no i'm saying i'm saying
that he quite rightly was robust
uh to understand um what the reasons are
to look at the data carefully and that's
the right way
to do this we've got to work together on
this this is not about
sort of you know finger-pointing or
playing petty politics and i hope
it doesn't become like that uh because
the the one thing we have to do now
is set politics aside i get it you know
oppositions have to oppose and they want
to try and bring down the government but
not at this time
where this is so crucial that we control
this virus and come out the other route
the circuit break is not happening any
time soon isn't it
we heard from trey's coffee yesterday
and she said uh it's i said i put it to
her that it won't happen in the next
couple of weeks to tie in with half term
and she said i don't believe so
is that your understanding well look my
understanding is
we want to let the tier system work
that's the right way
to go about this i think look i said to
you at the opening that this is a really
tough
balance between two harms the harm of
the virus and the harm if you have a
national lockdown
of an economic and health uh
consequences
i would much rather not have a a
national lockdown i'd much rather have
these local
uh tiered interventions that are much
clearer working with local government
and hopefully if we work together we can
actually control this virus but we we we
we quite rightly i think chris whittie
has said and and the prime minister
that we we you know we keep all our
options open too because we have to
protect lives
and save the nhs that is ultimately how
would you give this tier 3
system to work well so we have to make
sure that
um the scientists the experts
look at this we've got to bring down the
our number to one you know that the
scientists and the experts are saying
that we need a national lockdown
actually if you look at the sage advice
kay it said
all the interventions have associated
costs to them back to my
issue about you know that balancing two
harms the harm
of the virus and and the pandemic and
harm to the economy and to health
as well so that there are costs on on
both sides there's no easy decisions
everybody understands that minister but
it's confusing the information that you
are giving them it's much more
straightforward if you say like we said
in march
it's a national lockdown everybody's
impacted we'll see where we are in three
weeks the problem with that is
when you look at the death figures or
the uh the latest figures
from public health england it takes
three weeks for that information to come
through
so a lockdown is going to last longer
than three weeks if we go into one and
also
part of the problem is that right well
the problem with the log down okay
is that uh you log down an area like say
liverpool where uh you know infection
rates were
above seven hundred eight hundred per
hundred thousand
uh uh population whilst cornwall
is very low uh so this one size fits all
i think
does more harm as rishi sunak has talked
about as
chris whittie himself has talked about
because actually the economic harm
leads to other health consequences and
harms
that people also suffer so it's much
better
to do what we're doing which is the
local lockdowns the who has commended us
for this
as i said to you president macron saying
actually the app is working we don't
care what the friends you think i hear
you
we don't care what we care about is the
mixed messaging
it's not it's very clear there are three
tiers uh
that you can be into and if if the i'm
going to give those another couple of
weeks before we decide what then
and well rightly so because you've got
to try and work together to make sure
that people
act responsibly the tears are very
simple easy to understand for people
and let's let's do this together and
just to clarify greater manchester
and parts of lancashire will be going
into tier three today well as i say i'm
not going to
speculate matt hancock is going to make
a statement to parliament as to where
we are at uh but you can clearly see the
numbers the virus is is
the virus are watching especially if you
listen to what you have to say minister
i hear you
and and matt hancock is already and it's
flashing on your
uh ticker tape that is going to make a
statement uh to
parliament um because that's the right
way to do this okay
okay we understand how frustrating it is
for you as well and and i'm sure that my
viewers would want to say that they
appreciate the amount of time and
effort that all of your colleagues are
putting in but you also have to accept
the frustration that they feel when they
don't know whether they're going to have
a job
on monday well i hope they know that
this government is serious about
protecting jobs and protecting
opportunities and making opportunities
available
we put 200 billion pounds into the
economy to support
jobs to support businesses you know
whether it's the
furlough scheme or the bounce-back loans
we have
at every stage looked at what we need to
do with the economy i'm the business and
industry minister and i
speak to businesses every single day um
and we try and flex the interventions we
make so that they are fit for purpose
and i just think you know it's difficult
but it's right that we offer those areas
if they do go into tier three
two-thirds of wages and i think that's
the right thing to do plus universal
credit as well
which is the safety net i hear you and
we've run out of time and i haven't even
asked you about brexit are we are we
going to get a deal or not
well the prime minister's spoken to
charles michelle and to us of underlying
again
uh we'll wait for the outcome of the uh
meeting the european council meeting
and then the prime minister will make a
decision as to where we are we
absolutely want a deal
we want a canada style deal but if we
can't get a deal
rightly so we've got to allow businesses
to prepare i can't uh go to businesses
you know at sort of the 11th hour on the
31st of december so
now you have to prepare for this we have
to make a decision uh
much sooner to be able to allow
businesses to prepare and i think
well the prime minister will make that
decision i i don't want to pre-judge
where we are at
let's wait and see what happens at the
council as well